[Musik]
wir sind im Krieg sagt israelspräsident
nitan jau die radikalislamische Hamas
greift Israel massiv an tötet mindestens
100 Israelis das Land reagiert mit
Luftangriffen auf Stellungen der Hamas
fast 200 Menschen kommen dabei im
gazreif ums Leben die Welt hält den Atem
an und damit guten Abend an einem Tag an
dem Israel schwer unter Schock steht
eiskalt erwischt von dieser
Terrorattacke der radikalislamischen
Hamas wir gehen live zu unseren
Korrespondenten nach Washington kaairo
Berlin und natürlich nach Israel aktuell
beraten Krisenstäbe weltweit über diesen
Konflikt dessen Eskalationspotenzial
noch nicht absehbar
ist seit dem frühen Morgen hat die Hamas
bei ihrem Überraschungsangriff Städte im
Süden Israels mit Raketen beschossen
getroffen wurden vor allem Orte in der
Nähe des Gazastreifens aber auch in Tel
Aviv schlugen Geschosse ein zu Lande
über das Wasser und mit Gleitschirmen
drangen hamaskämpfer nach Israel ein
gemeinsam mit Mitgliedern der
Terrororganisation islamischer Jihad
erschossen und verletzten Sie dutzende
Israelis und auch viele Entführungen
nach Gaza soll es geben Christoph
desterell
hinter der Grenzmauer ein Zaun und
dahinter ein 2 km entfernt die ersten
israelischen Städte es ist früh morgens
die Hamas filmt ihren Angriff auf Israel
er wird ihren Feind völlig unvorbereitet
treffen kurz nach der Grenze erobern sie
einen Panzer und zerren dessen Fahrer
wahrscheinlich tot aus dessen Kabine
einen verletzten packen Sie auf ein
Motorrad und fahren ih nach Gaza
möglichst viele Geiseln lebend oder tot
das scheinen sich die Angreifer
vorgenommen zu haben und und während
hunderte Kämpfer in die israelischen
Städte nah an der Grenze ausschwärmen
fliegen Raketen von Gaza nach Israel
tausende zu viel um sie alle abzufangen
wie hier in Aschkelon treffen sie die
Israelis hart Menschen sterben überall
Zerstörung warum all das der Militärchef
der Hamas rechtfertigt
sich wir haben beschlossen den
israelischen Verbrechen mit gotteshilfe
ein Ende zu setzen damit der Feind
begreift dass die Zeit in der er Unheil
anrichten kann ohne zur Rechenschaft
gezogen zu werden vorbei ist auf offener
Straße Schießereien zwischen Angreifern
und Bewohnern ein lokaler Politiker wird
tödlich getroffen den ganzen Tag über
bekommt das israelische Militär die Lage
nicht in den Griff Israel überrumpelt
geschockt Bürger Israels wir befinden
uns im Krieg nicht in einer neuen Runde
der Gewalt sondern im Krieg erklärt
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu und sichtbar
außer sich droht einer seiner Offiziere
der Hammers sie hat die Tore der Hölle
zum Gazastreifen geö önet sie wird die
Verantwortung tragen und den Preis dafür
zahlen gegen Mittag steigen erste
Rauchwolken über Gaza auf israelische
Vergeltung und das Militär
veröffentlicht Bilder vom gezielten
Beschuss der radikalislamischen Hamas
wie es heißt kündigt die Mobilisierung
von 10tausenden Reservisten an aber
dieser Kampf droht ein so nicht
daagewesener zu werden immer mehr Videos
von Entführungen tauchen auf Frauen
junge ältere werden in Autos gezwungen
verschleppt egal in welchem Zustand
Richtung Gaza also dorthin wo längst
auch das Sterben begonnen hat durch die
Vergeltungsschläge hunderte Tote auf
beiden Seiten und immer noch kein Ende
wie Schlachtfelder sehen manche der
angegriffenen israelischen Städte aus
mit Überlebenden die nicht fassen können
was heute passiert ist in derot klammert
sich eine Frau an einen toten
Motorradfahrer und ruft ich gehe hier
nicht weg ich habe ihm die Augen
geschlossen sein Blut ist auf dem
Helml Bilder Michael bwerunge bei derot
also in der Nähe des nördlichen
gaserstreifens das Land ist schwer
geschockt wie ist aktuell die Situation
Michael also Moment fliegen auch hier
etwa 5 km nördlich von derot gerade
wieder sehr viele Raketen es ist
heftiges raketenabwehrfeuer zu hören das
hier ist quasi der letzte Checkpoint vor
der heißen Zone weiter geht es für
Zivilisten nicht zugleich ist es ein
Umschlagplatz für verletzte viele
Hubschrauber landen hier und die
Ambulanzen die man vielleicht im
Hintergrund sieht fahren dann die
Verletzten weiter in die Krankenhäuser
im Norden von Israel ab es gibt nur
wenig Berichte aus der heißen Kampfzone
es soll weiter in derot gekämpft werden
wo sich hamaskämpfer in einer
Polizeistation verschanzt haben und es
gibt zwei geisellagen wo hamaskämpfer
mehrere Dutzend Zivilisten in
geschlossenen Räumen gefangen halten und
das ist das große Problem jetzt der
Nacht für die israelische Armee wie soll
sie da vorgehen außerdem gibt es
tatsächlich bestätigt auch von der
Regierung zahlreiche
Entführungen von Soldaten in den
Gazastreifen Michael Israels
Sicherheitsapparat gehört ja zu den
besten der Welt wie konnte dieser
Sicherheitsapparat so eiskalt erwischt
werden das ist mit Sicherheit die große
Frage der Stunde die auch hier gestellt
wird ich habe sie heute morgen einem
Sprecher der des Generalstabs vorgelegt
und der hat mich lange angeguckt gesagt
das ist eine wichtige Frage und trocken
gesagt nächste Frage im Moment hat
dieses Land einfach keine Zeit sich
damit zu beschäftigen es gibt im Moment
so viele ungelöste Probleme es gibt
immer noch Kämpfe es gibt diese
geisellagen und die Luftangriffe auf
Gasa sind eher ein hilfloses Zeichen
natürlich wird man da auch militärische
infrast Struktur treffen aber eben auch
viele Zivilisten nur die aktuelle
Problematik die wird man damit nicht
bekämpfen Michael danke für den Moment
wir sprechen gleich weiter bevor wir
gleich live nach Washington außerdem und
auch nach Kairo gehen schauen wir
genauer auf die Hamas die diese blutige
Terrorattacke heute Morgen starteten die
radikal islamische Organisation wird
unter anderem von Iran unterstützt und
hat das Ziel Israel zu vernichten und
einen islamischen Staat zu errichten
mehr von David
Römhild maskiert schwer waffnet und
kompromisslos in ihren Mitteln die
palästinensergruppe Hamas ent steht Ende
der 80er während der ersten in die Fader
2006 gewinnt sie die Wahlen im
Gazastreifen kontrolliert seit einem
blutigen Bruderkrieg mit der gemäßigten
vertachbewegung das Gebiet ohne
demokratisch legitimiert zu sein die
Amas besteht aus unterschiedlichen
militärischen Gruppen umfasst aber auch
eine politische Partei und unterhält
Hilfsorganisationen und Schulen im
Gazastreifen womit sie sich Sympathien
und nach sichert demonstriert hier immer
wieder ihre Macht die Botschaft auch
heute wir sind bereit zu kämpfen wir
sind bereit zu sterben wir sind bereit
in israelisches Territorium vorzudringen
und die israelische Strategie die
palästinafage zu lösen indem man sie
militärisch zu befrieden glaubt diese
Strategie ist mit diesem Angriff heute
als gescheitert anzusehen die Hamas will
Israel vernichten und einen islamischen
Staat errichten EU und USA Stufen sie
als Terrororganisation ein und Terror
ist auch ihr vorrangiges Mittel um
solche Anschläge zu verhindern hat
Israel einen massiven Grenzzaun
errichtet den die Hamas nun überwunden
hat noch mal nach Israel zu Michael
bwerunge über die Motivlage wird ja
jetzt gerätselt warum kommt dieser
Angriff ausgerechnet
jetzt also dieser großangelegte
Überraschungsangriff der ist offenbar
von langer Hand vorbereitet und
organisiert worden und und es konnte
kein besseres Datum geben aus Sicht der
Mae als den Tag heute ist nämlich genau
einen Tag nach dem 50 jahrestag des
jomkipurkrieges wo Israel schon einmal
von zwei Armeen aus Ägypten und Syrien
überrascht worden ist natürlich ist
Israel Moment nicht existentiell bedroht
aber aus der Sicht der Hamas ist das ein
enormer propagandistischer Erfolg schon
jetzt danke für die Einschätzung nach
Israel Michael
beunge der
hat den Angriff auf Israel scharf
verurteilt wie blickt Washington auf
diese Eskalation was passiert jetzt in
der arabischen Welt wir wollen jetzt
genauer nachfragen bei goliniatai in
Cairo und Elma teson in Washington
zunächst zu dir goline wie reagiert die
arabische Welt auf diesen
Überraschungsangriff der
Hamas also auch wenn die Bevölkerungen
hier sich mit den Palästinensern
solidarisieren Ägypten und die Golf
Länder die rufen zu sofortiger
Deeskalation auf einige einige dieser
Länder betonen dabei die israelische
Verantwortung Saudiarabien macht das
indirekt das verweist auf die
israelische Besatzungspolitik es fordert
jetzt eine neue Friedensinitiative mit
Aussicht auf eine zwei staatenlösung nur
das könne diese Gewalt heute hier
verhindern es gibt natürlich andere in
der Region die jubeln das sind der Iran
das sind seine Verbündeten in der Region
das ist die hisbolla im Libanon das sind
die
proiranischen Milizen im Irak für sie
ist es heute ein Tag des Sieges und
damit steigt das Risiko dass hier in der
Region weitere Fronten eröffnet werden
dass beispielsweise die hisbolla der
Hamas zur Hilfe kommt dass es
beispielsweise mehr Auseinandersetzungen
gibt vermehrte Auseinandersetzungen gibt
zwischen Israel und Iran z.B in Syrien
Hamas und die hisbolla haben heute auch
sehr sehr deutlich gemacht dass der
heutige Tag eine Botschaft ist an alle
Araber die eine Normalisierung mit
Israel suchen oder diese bereits
umgesetzt haben es gab ja zuletzt sehr
deutliche Anzeichen für eine
saudischisraelische Annäherung und ein
solche friedensstil der dürfte nach dem
heutigen Tag erst einmal aufgeschoben
sein wenn nicht gar ganz torpediert
worden sein von den Ereignissen dann
jetzt weiter nach Washington zu Elmar
tbeson die USA Elma sind Israels
wichtigster Verbündeter wie hat sich das
Weiße Haus
positioniert ja Präsident Biden hat
natürlich mit Premierminister netan
telefoniert hat ihm jedwede
Unterstützung zugesagt und das betrifft
vor allen Dingen zwei Bereiche das eine
sind
aufklärungsinformationen aus der
luftauklärung der USA und das zweite
auch wenn notwendig Waffen und Munition
die USA haben ein Depot in Israel ausd
dem sind allerdings in den letzten
Monaten hundertausende von
Artilleriegranaten auch in die Ukraine
geliefert worden deswegen weiß man nicht
wie viel da zur Verfügung steht man hat
auch gewarnt Präsident Biden ganz
gezielt gewarnt alle Feinde Israels wenn
sie in irgendeiner Weise Vorteil daraus
ziehen wollten was da passiert also das
ist die Sorge vor einer Ausdehnung des
konflites man scheint hier in Washington
genauso überrascht wie in Israel selber
es gibt bisher keine Anzeichen dafür
dass die CIA Vorwarnungen in irgendeiner
Form hatte und man glaubt das ist ein
schwerer diplomatischer Schlag für die
wichtigste Initiative der USA natürlich
in dieser Region und das ist das schon
von goline angesprochene geplante
Abkommen oder die Annäherung zwischen
Saudi Arabien und Israel das so geht man
im Weißen Haus davon aus hat sich bis
auf weiteres zerschlagen vielen Dank
nach Washington und Kairo golini und
Elma aus Sorge dieser Konflikt könnte
auch bei uns zu Gewalt führen haben die
Sicherheitsbehörden israelische und
jüdische Einrichtungen jetzt unter
verstärkten Schutz gestellt als
gefährdet gelten z.B die Berliner
Synagoge und das jüdische Museum weil am
Abend ein jüdischer Feiertag beginnt
soll bundesweit die Polizeipräsenz
erhöht werden gehen wir jetzt in die
Hauptstadt zu Theo Kol Theo wie reagiert
Berlin schockiert und umfassend
solidarisch mit Israel aßministerin
bburg nannte den heutigen Tag eine zesur
und die Angriffe seinen durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen Nachbarn oder anderen in
der Region hat sie gewarnt sich der
Auseinandersetzung anzuschließen sie
meinte es bestehe die Gefahr einer
großen regionalen Eskalation und
gleichzeitig betont sie aber auch nur
eine politische Lösung können Leben in
Frieden und würde bringt der
außenpolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion der hat eine entschieden
härtere Gangart gegen den Iran gefordert
denn so Jürgen hart Iran stecke hinter
den Angriffen und die Waffen der Hamas
die stammten wohl auch zu einem großen
Teil aus dem Iran er fordert
beispielsweise das Iran Zentrum in
Hamburg zu schließen und die
revolutionsgarten auf die Terrorliste zu
setzen der Krisenstab der
Bundesregierung hat heute getagt und Red
dringend von Reisen nach Israel und in
die palästinensischen Gebiete ab hab
vielen Dank nach Berlin Theo Koll war
das weitere Hintergründe zu den
Angriffen der Hamas sehen Sie auch in
einem ZDF Spezial gleich nach unserer
Sendung und ganz aktuell informieren wir
Sie jederzeit auch in unserem Liveblog
auf ZDF
heute Bundespräsident Frank Walter
Steinmeier hat sich nach einem Treffen
mit US-Präsident beiden optimistisch
gezeigt dass die USA weiter
Militärhilfen für die Ukraine leisten
werden steinmeier sagte in Washington
beiden habe ihm versichert auf die USA
sei Verlass man werde die Ukraine im
Kampf für ihre Freiheit und ihre
Demokratie weiter
unterstützen in Bayern und Hessen sind
morgen Landtagswahlen Favoriten sind
hier wie dort die Amtsinhaber in Hessen
dürfte die CDU von Ministerpräsident
Boris Rhein stärkste Fraktion bleiben
mögliche Koalitionspartner hier grüne
oder SPD in Bayern liegt
Ministerpräsident Söder mit seiner CSU
VN er will mit den Freien Wählern weiter
regieren wir wollen jetzt ins ZDF
Wahlstudio gehen zu bertina Schausten
guten Abend bertina was ist das
Spannende an beiden
Wahlen ja wir haben unruhige Zeiten mit
Krieg und Krise mit schwierigen Themen
Migration Klimawandel da ist es zumal
zur Halbzeit der ampelregierung im Bund
schon sehr interessant wenn gleich zwei
Flächenländer wählen immerhin rund 14
Millionen Wahlberechtigte die morgen an
die
nen gerufen werden und für die
ampelparteien zeichnet sich wenig
Erfreuliches ab für die SPD ist Bayern
ohnehin Diaspora aber in Hessen wo es
eigentlich was zu holen gäbe droht der
SPD ein neues historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis weniger die Grünen aber die
Liberalen müssen sich auf Verluste
einstellen und hoffen dass sie zumindest
in Hessen im Landtag bleiben mit Markus
Söder und Boris rin in Hessen scheinen
die Wahlsieger der Union ziemlich
festzustehen gleichzeitig wird die AFD
in beiden Ländern zulegen auf
westdeutsche Höchstwerte und da wird
bestimmt die Frage diskutiert wer trägt
dafür die Verantwortung also ich
empfehle dabei zu sein diese Wahl hält
viel Diskussionsstoff bereit wir melden
uns ab 17:30 Uhr morgen hier aus dem
zfalstudio Danke schön an bertina
Schausten Afghanistan ist von mehreren
starken
erdbebenheimgesucht worden das
Epizentrum lag in der Provinz herad im
Westen des Landes nahe der Grenze zu
Iran von mindestens 120 Toten und mehr
als 1000 verletzten berichten örtliche
Behörden weil viele Menschen verschüttet
wurden dürften die Zahlen aber noch
steigen erst im vergangenen Jahr hatte
ein Beben der Stärke 5,9 mehr als 1000
Menschen das Leben
gekostet wir sind jetzt beim Sport Katja
die
frauenfußballnationalmannschaft hat
vorerst einen neuen Trainer ja zumindest
interimsweise genau Horst rubesch ist
zurück an der Seitenlinie für die
weiterhin erkrankte Martina
vostecklenburg vor 5 Jahren folgte er
auf Steffy Jones und war damals schon
äußerst erfolgreich und
beliebt es soll der Wunsch des Teams
gewesen sein dass der 72-Jährige
übernimmt Horst rubesch derzeit
nachwuchschef beim HSV für mich ist es
eine Herzensangelegenheit ich musste bei
der Anfrage nicht lange überlegen als
der Hamburger zum ersten Mal als
Interimscoach im April 2018
eingesprungen war spielten leer Schüler
und Co locker auf und sicherten sich mit
ihm das WM-Ticket Martina fosst
Tecklenburg übernahm scheiterte aber
2019 im Viertelfinale und zuletzt als
EM2 schon in der Vorrunde in Australien
seitdem ist sie krank geschrieben ihre
Zukunft ungewiss robesch soll nun
zunächst die Olympia Qualifikation
schaffen zur Fußball buundesliga der
Männer und zu girassie der Stuttgarter
hat mit seinem Hattrick heute einen
Rekord in der Fußball buundesliga
aufgestellt 13 Tore in sieben Spielen
gab's noch nie hier die Ergebnisse des
siebten Spieltags Stuttgart mit girassie
gewinnt also gegen Wolfsburg 3:1 der BVB
dreht einen Rückstand zum 4:2 gegen
Union Berlin leipzig-bchum trennen sich
0:0 augsburg-dmstadt
1:2 das Abendspiel Bremen Hoffenheim
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio und
bereits gestern glad Mainz 2:2 in der
Tabelle Stuttgart vorn mindestens über
Nacht dahinter Dortmund dann Bayer und
Bayern die beide morgen spielen keine
Veränderung momentan auf den Plätzen 5
bis 10 auf dem Heidenheim steht
darmstand springt von 15 auf 11 und im
Tabellenkeller weiterhin ohne Sieg
Bochum Mainz und
Köln alle wichtigen Bilder und stimmen
dieses Spieltags heute Abend im
Aktuellen Sportstudio von 2 20:15 Uhr an
zu Gast sind Ruder weleltmeister Oliver
Zeitler und die Gymnastin Daria
fafolomeev die Ende August bei den
Weltmeisterschaften alle zu vergebenen
Titel gewinnen konnte und die dafür
gestern Abend in Istanbul im Beisein von
IOC Präsident thomas Bach als beste
europäische Nachwuchsathletin geehrt
wurde Glückwunsch dazu und sie bringt
alle Goldmedaillen mit heute nicht
schlecht vielen Dank Katja so die
Wetteraussichten die gibt's gleich mit
Christ
Orben alles zum Angriff auf Israel ab
22:55 Uhr auch im heutejournal mit
Marietta Slomka und gleich im Anschluss
auch ein ZF Spezial zur Eskalation in
Nahost das war's von uns morgen hier für
Sie Barbara hallweg auf
[Musik]
bald guten Abend eine scharfe Luftmassen
Grenze liegt im Moment mit Wolken und
Regen über Deutschland so fließt in den
Südwesten ungewöhnlich warme und in den
Nordosten herbstlich kühle Luft so
sinken die Temperaturen heute Nacht im
Nordosten auf 3 bis 9° sonst gibt es
meist 10 bis 14° im Südwesten kühlt
etwas mehr aus hier ist der Himmel auch
meist klar im Bereich der Front gibt's
aber viele Wolken und Regen in den
östlichen Landesteilen können noch mal
10 l pro quadratmeer zusammenkommen
inklusive stürmischer Böhen auf den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen dahinter trht
der Wind auf Nord und es lockert wieder
auf mit diesen drei Bereichen haben wir
es auch morgen zu tun vom Emsland bis
zum Erzgebirge und zum Bayerischen Wald
gibt's viele Wolken anfangs etwas Regen
der nachmittags aber nachlässt im
Nordosten da ist es länger sonnig bis zu
7ben Sonnenstunden sind möglich genauso
wie im Südwesten aber was die
Temperaturen betrifft gibt's gewaltige
Unterschiede im Nordosten herbstliche 14
bis 16° im Südwesten spätsommerliche 23
bis
26°. am Montag wird der
Temperaturunterschied erstm noch größer
bevor sich dann aber aus Südwesten noch
einmal die mildere Luft durchsetzt und
damit auf Wiedersehen